على الجانب التقني والاقتصادي وفي سباق
الجدل وتصريحاته يفوزوا حتما الى المسك
الذي لم يمر يوما في 20 22 دون ان يكون
محور احاديث العالم وربما الفوضى التي
حدثت قبل وبعد استحواذه على تويتر سببا
اساسيا في هذا الزخم الملياردير يقدم عرضا
لاستحواذ على تويتر للماضي ويقبل تويتر
العرض فيتراجع ماسك عن الصفقه وذلك بحجه
تويتر لم يتعاونوا في الكشف عن الحجم
الحسابات الوهميه على منصه تويتر
مع اقتراب المحاكمه يعيد ماسك تقديمه عرضه
يستحوذ على المنصه في اكتوبر ليبدا فصلا
جديدا من التخبط والانتقدات يسرح ماسك
اكثر من نصف موظفي المنصه يقيل مهندسين
الموقع الذين ينتقدونه ويفرد رسوما على
علامه التوثيق الزرقاء او خدمه تويتر
واخيرا يسال في استطلاع ما اذا كان يجب
عليه التنحي عن منصبه كمديرا تنفيذي لت
رغم التعاهد باحترام النتائج يصوت الناس
نعم لكن يبقى في منصبه على اي حال وخارج
تويتر فقد ماسك لقد اغنى رجل في العالم
بعد ان خسرت تسلا نحو 40 مليار دولار من
قيمتها السوقيه لتصل الى ما دون النصف
تريليون دولار